now
back inside delhi's Southern Kitchen
Chef Mario's whipping up all kinds of
Super Bowl fun yeah oh man I want to eat
it all you excited for this one what are
we doing now this is my favorite it's Dr
Pepper Hennessy barbecue wings
Dr Pepper Hennessy barbecue yes you got
to start the Super Bowl right
okay just in a saute pan I just want to
warm a little bit of butter
into that butter I'm gonna add just a
little bit of chopped garlic I'm just
gonna let this get a little warm here I
don't want to be careful not to burn
your garlic and this is your specialty
okay this is mine
my favorite
and that's what that flame is gonna do
it's just gonna
cook all that alcohol down so now you
just have that rich flavor with the
garlic the butter and that Dr Pepper Dr
Pepper if I like to take a vinegar and a
sweet barbecue sauce mixture okay that's
what we have here so the sweets would
get to Carolina yes and the vinegar
that's also a Carolina okay yes they
have both they have a Lexington and
sometimes we have a suite and in the
Carolinas we like both so Nellie's got
North Carolina
so I like to mix the two because I'm a
I'm a huge fan of the sugar and the
sweet of the sweet barbecue so I add a
little bit of
a tad bit of honey
and then we just want to reduce this
sauce down
and just just make it thicker so we're
just going to let it continue to boil
and as it boils it's just going to
thicken up on us you want to
continuously stir it but then when you
see it boiling you just want to turn it
down so I just took Little Wing gas
these are just the simple small wings
that you can get from the store here
and what I'm going to do is I'm just
going to let those wings simmer in this
sauce for a little bit and that's gonna
create a nice little glaze on them how
do you know when it's done they're
already done your wings are done and
what you want you want to do is you just
want your sauce to just bubble boom
Super Bowl ready
boom right there okay we got the recipe
the instructions all of the items I've
been talking about all week
eightnewsnow.com I look really